I first heard of Ebola on the 24th of
May and that was the first time I went
on goggle and copy what evil eyes it was
a kind of very scary and on and on
imaginable name what what the hell is a
bola you turn off the garage what did
you what did that come from
this is the verb first time that Ebola
has struck Sara loom so people have
little or no preparedness when when we
first had Ebola the first the area
that's affected is the opposition
political parties stronghold so there
are lot of misconceptions that oh census
is coming in December and a country
supposed to have census in December and
so the tryna do what the Chinese guys
challenge right now is to kill some of
us and reduce the numbers but then as we
get along the reality begins to show
itself so denial was not with her issue
anymore it's about the level of
understanding and the level of literacy
that people to have the outbreak has
tremendously affected a lifestyle of
people right now around 8 o'clock 9
o'clock
everyone will be running home there are
no more nightclubs there were no more
pops no more restaurants people don't
shake hands anymore people don't hog
anymore everyone is suspicious about
someone
my kids have been home since July and
they cannot go to school because schools
are not functioning that will happen on
its of economic development of the
country a country that is recovering
from 11 years brutal civil war as much
as the immoral is killing people in the
country it's the poverty it's the fear
of of being left alone it's the feeling
of hopelessness a health system was just
not prepared for an emergency
like Ebola we were struggling already on
a regular basis or a daily basis in
providing health care for people the
basic primary health care we have very
limited number of medical practitioners
especially doctors all the whole and
centers we have our food all the
hospitals are full we will die off I
potentially would die off of stress we
will die off common illnesses fatality
related issues if you are pregnant in
Sierra Leone today it will be a very
difficult situation because where do you
go to hospital
people's life at risk nothing is working
in the country it's as if you live in a
wireless in in a world that everything
is not working not in the same name and
all you're looking for is a divine grace
you